- Do you like our spectrum videos?
If so, we actually made a game
where you can play at home
with your friends and family.
We made a Kickstarter and
if you wanna go check it out
and support it, that would be amazing.
You can actually even have maybe one
of your prompts be a part of the game.
Like, clothes and makeup have no gender.
What do you think?
Do they?
I don't know.
We're gonna find out.
- [Kendall] And then I'm
also, like, a gym rat.
So another day it could be
just, like, we hit legs.
We get Chipotle.
- Yeah. I don't work out too much.
(upbeat techno music)
I'm Tyler, I'm 18 from Colorado.
I'm a summer camp instructor
and a script writer.
I think my style is kind
of a mixture between, like,
emo, kind of my own
clothing that I've made,
I think there's gonna be a
jump in fashion really soon
with, like, this casual cowboy thing.
So, you know, I have, I
have of this right here,
and on the back too.
I love girls that, like,
have their own style,
you know,
that I can look at them and be like,
I have not seen that before,
or even just a piece that
I haven't seen before.
It's awesome to see girls kind of
adopt their own fashion sense.
(playful, suspenseful music)
Okay.
Number one, what was the
decision behind the cowboy boots?
- [Mikki] I used to be a horse girl,
so I decided to wear the cowboy boots,
cuz it goes, like, with
my old horse girl self
and my new style, which
is more, like, gothic.
- Tell me like, if I were
to take you out on a date,
what would you want to do?
- [Mikki] Maybe we can
go, like, vintage shopping
and I can pick an outfit for you,
and you can pick out an outfit for me.
- I love it.
That's a great answer.
I'm over here telling people
to take note on that one,
right there.
Number two.
What was the decision
behind the, the shoes today?
- [Aala] I like square boots a lot.
So, I thought it would gave
me a little seventies vibe
with the flare pants, you know?
- Yeah.
What would you do out on a date with me?
- [Aala] To be honest,
I'm pretty impulsive.
So, I love planning on the spot.
On my free time, I like driving
around listening to music.
So, that has to be
incorporated into the plan.
- Absolutely.
- [Aala] For sure.
- Number three.
- [Elena] I like to stand out, like,
with little pieces when
it comes to my outfit,
cuz I'm very into, like,
little vintage details
and everything.
So, if we were going on our first date,
we would most likely
be going to a drive-in,
cuz that's like one of the
main things that I like to do.
- Awesome.
- [Cally] These are my sparkly stompers.
(magical wind chime)
- That's a great answer.
- [Cally] They're my favorite shoes.
I wear them too much, probably.
And you could kick people with them,
and dance in them, and do
a lot of things in them.
- That's awesome.
- [Cally] I would want
to go to a bookstore,
and we could pick out
books for each other.
Maybe make playlists for each other.
- I like that one.
- [Cally] What would
you put on my playlist?
- French music.
- [Cally] French music?
- Yeah. That's the wild card.
- [Cally] Can, can you speak any French?
- Actually? I like your outfit is:
(speaks French)
I'm pretty sure that's
how you pronounce it.
(Google translate speaks French)
Sorry if it's not to people watching.
Star-laced Converse, I like it.
I like it.
It's very summer camp instructor vibes.
- [Jacquelyn] I like
when my outfit has, like,
two matching call colors or,
like, two main point colors,
So it was brown first and then
I needed some green magic.
So.
- They do work.
- [Jacquelyn] For my perfect first date,
I really like picnics.
So, I would prefer,
like, an evening picnic.
Maybe like 3:00 to 5:00 PM.
Okay, Five. Okay.
Number six.
Very clean Docs.
- [Kendall] Yeah. These are my Docs,
but they make me feel really powerful
and, like, taller than everyone,
and I can step on someone.
And then also, I don't know,
I feel like it attracts
like skater boys and,
I don't know,
I think that's like
kind of helpful for me.
- [Cally] Me and you, baby.
We can stop on people together.
- I do skate.
- [Kendall] Oh yeah.
- Well what's your ideal date?
- [Kendall] I'm a very,
like, active person.
So I think it'd be really fun
if we could go, like, surfing together
- Yes
- [Kendall] or snowboarding,
(sighs)
- Even though I've never gone.
And then I'm also, like, a gym rat.
So another day it could be
just, like, we hit legs,
We get Chipotle.
I don't know, up to you.
- Yeah. I don't work out too much.
(laughs)
- I'll try.
We'll definitely try that.
(upbeat techno music)
Okay.
I'm going to have to eliminate four.
(elimination beep)
- [Cally] I'm excited to see you now.
- Sorry. Sadly, I
- [Cally] Show me your face.
- [Announcer] You can come on out.
- Oh, I'm sorry.
- Oh my God.
Eliminate me, for my shoes?
- It's just
- [Contestant] Not the shoes, man
- Not the shoes, not the sparkly stompers.
So can you do a heart on camera?
(melancholy music)
- I'm sorry.
Thank you.
Sorry.
I like the fit a lot.
- [Cally] Yeah, you should.
(sighs)
(upbeat techno music)
- Okay.
I was just gonna ask you guys kind of,
when you're looking for someone to date,
what do you look for in a guy?
- [Mikki] I don't know.
I like when a guy's, like, confident.
I do like when a guy
can like pull off, like,
feminine clothing.
I think that's really attractive.
- That's, like, my
favorite part of fashion,
is watching people just absolutely break
what everyone else thinks is fashion.
I think that's the coolest part.
Number two.
What do you look for in a guy?
- [Aala] You know, I always like
trying different clothing styles
and, you know, experimenting with that.
So if I can find someone
who's into that too,
then, you know, best of both worlds
- That's awesome.
- [Aala] For both the both of us.
- Number three
- [Elena] First and foremost,
I just wanna make sure that
they're confident and everything
and that they're not
afraid to speak their mind.
And when it comes of fashion as well,
I love it when they express themselves
in a different level that lets too much,
at, like, a deep, darker emotion.
- [Jacquelyn] I like to
look for their smile first.
I feel like, when someone
has a really pretty smile,
like, you tell they're like a nice person.
- [Kendall] I know it's,
like, kind of weird,
but I love when guys are overalls.
I don't know why, but that's
like so attractive to me.
- Okay, good.
I like that.
Yeah.
(upbeat techno music)
- I'm going to have to
eliminate number three.
(elimination beep)
- Sorry.
- [Elena] Hello.
- Can I give you hug?
- Yeah.
- Thank you.
- I'm sorry, I stepped on your shoe.
- I love your fit, it's so cool.
- Thank you so much,
I love yours
- Okay, these match amazingly.
Like, this is awesome.
I love this.
If I looked at the whole
fit with everything,
then I would definitely,
I would've definitely let you stay longer.
- Yeah. I love your fit.
I love the little like
strings on your pants.
- Bro, don't spoil it.
I'm kidding, I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
- I'm sorry (laughs)
Bye
- Yeah, bye.
- Definitely sad that I had
to make that elimination.
She's very cute.
So.
(sighs)
Okay.
I think I'm gonna have to
eliminate number three.
(elimination beep)
- Bye.
- I like your tattoos.
- Thank you.
I love your necklace.
Does it connect?
- Yeah.
(mumbles)
- I could have taken one.
(upbeat techno music)
All right.
Number one.
If I was having a bad day,
just not really feeling it,
how would you come up
and interact with me?
- [Mikki] I would probably
ask you like, what's wrong?
Why are you feeling this way?
And then depending how you react,
I would ask if you'd wanna be left alone.
But if, like, you wanted
me to talk to you,
like, help you feel a little better.
- Yeah.
Good, I like that.
- Maybe crack a few jokes
That's good.
I like the between there.
- I'm really into like gift giving.
So I'd probably make
you a little something
and, like, put it on like the counter
and be like, oh, like, here you go.
- I like that.
- [Aala] Cheer you up a little bit,
A basket of some sort.
- [Kendall] I would start
with a peace offering.
So maybe, like, some coffee if I have it,
maybe some sushi.
And then, personally,
my love language is physical touch.
So, like, I always wanna
cuddle with someone
or watching movies and stuff
and just like, I don't know.
I love, like, I'll be the big spoon too.
That's cool with me.
(upbeat techno music)
- So, I'm gonna have to
eliminate number two.
(elimination beep)
I'm so sorry
(contestants say goodbyes)
- Oh, I'm so sorry.
- It's okay.
I love your outfit.
- Thank you, I love yours too.
- I love everything about it.
This is awesome.
So, this necklace, I couldn't
like take my eyes off it.
- Thank you.
I love the sunglasses.
- Thank you so much.
- Super cute.
Shoes, nice.
Tattoos, nice.
These two are catches.
So, you got a good line up coming up.
- Well, that's good.
- [Announcer] Are you ready
for your final elimination?
- Yeah.
I'm gonna have to take a
second to think on this one.
Oh, this is so hard.
I think I'm going to have to eliminate
number two.
(elimination beep)
This is not a decision
that I wanted to make.
I'm so sorry.
I love your outfit.
- Thank you.
- You're very cute.
- Thank you, I love your
pearls, they're so pretty.
- Thank so much.
- [Announcer] All right.
You ready to meet your final choice?
- Yes, sir.
- Hey, what's up?
- Hey, nice to meet you.
- I love your style.
You're, like, exactly like I pictured it.
- I love your tattoos.
- Give me a hug.
I love it.
I love the fit.
- Thank you.
- This is exactly,
when I say casual cowboy,
this is, this is the future
of, of fashion right here.
We need a pose together.
This is, this is, we are icons together.
- Actually, all of us will be
going on the date without you.
- Yeah, we're all gonna hang out.
- Can I come, too?
(upbeat outro music)